o pessoal boa tarde sou maurício villar
é um prazer estar aqui obrigado pelo
convite
queria começar a minha fé
pra vocês quem aqui se irrita todos os
dias
ficar uma duas três às vezes até quatro
horas no trânsito
peguei algum em que aí quem aqui se
irrita esperar 30 40 50 minutos
seu ônibus chegar pior que se irritar
quem é que acha isso normal
acho que faz parte do dia a dia faz
parte de uma realidade de uma cidade uma
grande metrópole como são paulo
quando eu tinha mais ou menos a idade de
vocês eu achava isso normal
eu gastava até duas horas no trânsito
para ir de casa até a faculdade e achava
que aproveitava aquele tempo ouvindo
música estudando inglês
às vezes até lendo achava que tava
aproveitando o tempo e aí surge uma
oportunidade na minha vida eu fui
estudar fora
fiquei dois anos e meio na europa
fazendo uma dupla graduação
fiquei dois anos e meio na frança e de
diversas experiências que eu vivi nesse
período o mais legal é que o que
aconteceu na primeira semana lá foi o
que mais marcou
alguns estudantes franceses levaram os
estudantes estrangeiros para conhecer a
cidade para ver a cultura pra ver um
pouco do dia a dia ea gente se deparou
com a principal avenida da cidade
completamente obras eram quatro vias de
carro por aí quatro para voltar
eles estavam transformando aquilo em uma
faixa para aí uma pra voltar
o vlt de superfície uma ciclofaixa ser
agregada e um baita calçadão para
pedestres
eu acostumado com a realidade daqui
pensei esses caras tão malucos é que vai
travar cidade ninguém vai andar vai
ficar aquele trânsito maluco igual são
paulo que eles estão fazendo
não me contive perguntei eu lembro até
hoje a resposta que eles deram
é exatamente isso que a gente quer
a gente quer que as pessoas diz
priorizem o uso do carro
a gente quer que as pessoas tenham a
pontos a possibilidade de usar outras
formas de locomoção e comecei a reparar
as pessoas de fato não achavam normal
ficar quatro horas no trânsito todo dia
quem morava longe trocava de meio de
transporte várias vezes durante o dia e
este carro até um trem pegava o trem até
o centro da cidade trocava por um metrô
ao sair do metrô pegava uma bicicleta ia
de bicicleta até a faculdade uma
bicicleta como meio de transporte
foi exatamente no ano em que eu cheguei
na frança em 2005 que 22 mil bicicletas
foram distribuídas em mais de duas mil
estações e aquilo foi chamado de sistema
de transporte de bicicletas
compartilhadas
o velib felipe francês são duas palavras
vê lo e libertê que significam bicicleta
e liberdade
resolvi experimentar aquela saudade
liberdade e me apaixonei
queria usar a bicicleta todos os dias
todos os tempos para ir à padaria para
ir à faculdade pra ir pro cinema para
voltar da balada acre me transformou
transformou a forma de enxergar a cidade
me transformou o tanto que quando eu
voltei para o brasil
resolvi fazer um tcc para construir um
sistema de bicicletas compartilhadas
aqui no nosso país afinal de contas se
lá fora funcionava porque aqui não ia
funcionar
fiz meu tcc passei me formei apresentei
por uma banca de professores que
adoraram a ideia apoiar um projeto e com
duas estações e quatro bicicletas a
gente começou um piloto na cidade
universitária aqui em são paulo quatro
bicicletas enquanto eu estava resolvendo
os primeiros problemas de eletrônica e
do sistema para travar a bicicleta e
liberar a gente fazia até 90 viagens por
dia com quatro bicicletas
aquilo me deu uma energia me motivou de
um jeito incrível era óbvio que as
pessoas queriam outras formas para se
locomover não queriam ficar no trânsito
elas queriam outras opções encontrei uns
loucos que também acreditavam nesse
sonho estavam completamente irritados
com o trânsito em são paulo
ele fundou uma empresa 100 mil sócios
até hoje
e começamos o negócio vendemos um
projeto com seis estações e 50
bicicletas para instalar na riviera de
são lourenço no litoral paulista estufam
o peito era muito óbvio que queria
crescer que todo mundo ia querer
a gente ia logo logo está no brasil
inteiro
e aí as dificuldades apareceram lembro
até hoje dia 22 de dezembro de 2012 caiu
aquela chuva de verão
mas aquela chuva que destrói tudo que
destruiu completamente nossas estações
a vedação não aguentou a água infiltrou
que motor da eletrônica uma estação
começou de choque
foi um desespero inferno mas a gente não
desistiu
meus três sócios ficavam nas estações
emprestando a bike na mão
afinal de contas o sistema tinha que
funcionar enquanto eu ficava no
apartamento de um amigo tentando
resolver salvar tudo que a gente tinha
perdido a gente recomeçou do zero
o que a gente tinha planejado durar dois
meses para instalar o sistema deixar
tudo rodando próximo projeto durou um
ano e meio mas aquilo transformou a
gente transformou a argentina uma equipe
unida numa equipe que sabia o que queria
fazer e sócios que acreditava naquele
negócio de verdade é sobre isso
e falar com vocês sobre transformação
a vida não é uma linha reta as coisas
vão mudar estejam abertos para isso a
bicicleta transformou a minha vida
a bicicleta um sistema um mecanismo
relativamente simples que se popularizou
no século 19 que transformou as cidades
que mudou a vida das pessoas
transformou a minha vida e as cidades
depois da transformação da bicicleta
passaram por outras transformações
a indústria automobilística veio colocou
um novo meio de se ver disse locomover
nas cidades
o carro protegido da chuva rápida e
eficiente capaz de levar diversas
pessoas num único veículo
isso é uma transformação gigantesca a
cidade se prepararam para recebeu veio o
carro no dia a dia
investiram isso é onde a gente chegou e
não me leve a mal não vim aqui na feira
falar mal de carro
o carro não é um vilão
é óbvio que a indústria automobilística
se desenvolve move a economia e vai
achar formas sustentáveis e eficientes
para continuar desenvolvendo o carro mas
a gente não pode planejar as cidades
para um meio de transporte só pensa em
quantas vezes você deixa seu carro no
estacionamento e ainda tem duas quadras
para chegar até o destino final
você não tem uma calçada decente para
andando
todos nós somos pedestres nem que seja
23 minutos por semana todo mundo aqui é
pedestre
a cidade precisa ser planejada para os
pedestres
quantas pessoas moram em regiões
afastadas e tem que vir para o centro
urbano para trabalhar para estudar
não dá pra todo mundo ver indicar não
tem espaço
as cidades precisam de meio de
transporte de massa
o corredor de ônibus trem metrô e
aqueles trás
esqueçam por é muito perto para indicar
mas é muito longe pra ir a pé de
bicicleta cai como uma luva trajetos até
56 quilômetros que são 70% de todos os
deslocamentos que acontece em são paulo
e as cidades começaram a perceber isso
começaram a ser transformado é incrível
ver essa transformação acontecendo
coisas que a gente não conseguia
imaginar a cinco dez anos atrás uma
avenida paulista lotada de bicicletas
uma avenida faria lima completamente
lotada no horário de pico com bikes
não sei quem sabe aqui mas a ciclovia da
faria lima é a terceira ciclovia mais
utilizada do mundo aqui tá do nosso lado
em são paulo essa transformação está
acontecendo não é à toa que a nossa
estação mais utilizada fica na faria
lima no largo da batata
são milhares e milhares de pessoas que
pegam a bicicleta todos os dias pra
fazer aquela última perna do
deslocamento era difícil de imaginar em
2010 quando tudo começou em uma empresa
de mobilidade urbana poderia ter 16 mil
bicicletas na américa latina em três
países diferentes
mais de 15 cidades com mais de 900
funcionários fazendo quase dois milhões
e meio de viagens por mês e só no começo
crescendo e dobrando de tamanho todos os
anos era difícil imaginar isso é o mais
legal mais engraçado é que tudo começou
de uma transformação uma transformação
pessoal que não contei para vocês mas
quando tinha 18 19 anos
o meu sonho aqui fazer engenharia era
projetar carros
cheguei até estagiar na indústria
automobilística a bicicleta me
transformou hoje transforma a vida de
milhares de pessoas e transforma as
nossas cidades
transformando nos próximos anos não
esteja aberto da transformação que pode
acontecer na vida de vocês
obrigado
[Aplausos]